I think the idea fixing the euro is very  tough I think there's some countries of  this juncture if we're going to go along  the lines that have been postulated that  I will have to leave the euro and I  think it's as long as when the transfer  mechanism tends to break down and when  other countries don't want to transfer  things then certain countries will leave  the euro and become more competitive and  as a result to become more competitive  their citizens are going to be better  off and they're going to have greater  growth a currency only works if the  preconditions are correct the  preconditions for currency working or  free mobility of the labor and capital  and prices adjusting accordingly and as  Europe is not seems to be interested in  that model but if you had that model  then you could have a single currency  you